Грудень уже добігає кінця, а в Карпатах снігу майже немає.
Зимовий бізнес Івана Яцика вже не перший рік рятує ось ця снігова гармата.
засніжили штучним снігом за 10 днів.
Тож, сезон відкрито, і сюди з'їхалися перші гості.
Утім, у Івана нові страхи: через епідемію коронавірусу досі не зрозуміло,
чи можуть працювати бугельні підйомники і якщо так - то за яких умов.
Розумієте, якщо держава встановила правила, то треба грати за правилами.
Дають можливість працювати в умовах карантину -  честь і хвала їм.
Якщо б  заборонили взагалі, то чекали би поки скасують.
Такий локдаун з правом перебувати на повітрі, як на мене, це нормально.
Гори штучного снігу - і стільки ж туристів.
Біля витягу на одну з гірськолижних трас курорту "Буковель" багатометрова черга.
Дистанція тут - лише у довжину лиж, а не в рекомендовані півтора метра.
Аби швидше потрапити на верхівку, в підйомники сідає максимальна кількість лижників.
Відповідальність за дотримання карантинних норм мають брати на себе туристи,
а не адміністрація курорту. Так вважають його власники.
Це черга, в той момент,  коли переходять на вечірнє катання.
Але я хочу сказати, що кожна людина сама себе має контролювати.
Ні одна держава світу не може проконтролювати всіх і вся.
Якщо ти сам себе не стимулюєш до захисту, то ніхто тебе не стимулює.
Ніхто не слідкує за масковим режимом і в приміщеннях.
Приміром, в інформаційному центрі курорту, де також чимале скупчення людей.
А туристів ставатиме ще більше.
Адже очікують що сюди з’їдуться не лише ті, хто традиційно відпочиває в Карпатах на новорічні свята,
а й ті українці, які раніше віддавали перевагу курортам Німеччини, Франції та Італії.
У цьому році у нас високе завантаження -  наразі  маємо 85-90%.
На Новий рік вже все продано. Ми не вимагаємо ПЛР-тестів,
адже в нас окремі котеджі з окремими входами,
тобто вони розташовані на достатній відстані один від одного.
Після кожного виїзду ми проводимо дезінфекцію і кварцування кожного номеру.
І є антисептики в місцях громадського користування.
В аптеці "Буковелю" можна придбати ПЛР-тести, один коштує 850 гривень.
Ще за додаткових 150 гривень у медпункті розкажуть, як його правильно здати.
Однак ще жоден турист не приходив з таким проханням.
Тестів поки не було. Звернення з температурою були.
Найближча лікарня від "Буковелю", де лікують хворих на "ковід", знаходиться за 40 кілометрів -
це майже 50 хвилин їзди гірськими дорогами, в іншому курортному містечку - Яремче.
У міській лікарні вже лікували від "ковіду" кількох киян.
Утім, не всі туристи, які звернулися до лікарні з високою температурою,
згодні провести свою відпустку в палаті.
Туристи тут довго не затримуються, бо...
не хочуть чекати, вони хочуть  кататися на лижах.
ПЛР брати - то треба день почекати.
Вони той день - хто чекає, а хто й не чекає.
Температуру збили та й поїхали в "Буковель".
Зараз очікуємо, що за тиждень їх буде навала тут.
З "ковідними" хворими лікарня почал а працювати наприкінці вересня.
Тут є два інфекційні відділення:
перше окреме від лікарні з окремими боксами і кисневим забезпеченням біля кожного ліжка.
А для другого переобладнали відділення травмпункту.
Перепрофілювалися на інфекціоністів і лікарі травматологи.
Тепер, після розширення, лікарня готова прийняти 60 хворих.
Нині тут лежать 12 пацієнтів з підтвердженим "ковідом", усі місцеві.
Та без жорсткого локдауну і закриття гірськолижного курорту
ситуація може разюче погіршитися.
Вони кажуть, що там свіже повітря.
Але ж чомусь в Австрії закрили. І в Італії закрили... То там шо?
Думаю, що там ліпше, ніж у нас, але все одно закрили.
Думаю, що треба закривати.
Тому що не буде куди класти хворих.
На даний час місця є,
але день-два - і вже не буде.
Дезінфектор для рук, лижного взуття та шоломів і для очищення приміщення.
А ще очікують доставки партії захисних масок.
Михайло Борейчак - власник двох котеджів у Яблуниці.
Після успішного літа готується до не менш насиченої зими:
на січень і майже на весь лютий котеджі заброньовано.
Очікує навіть гостей з Латвії.
У нас відбулось літо, яке воно було...
і такої кількості людей, що мене вже нічим не здивувати.
Ви не уявляєте, що тут було літом. Тут був мурашник!
Михайло ще навесні, аби не порушувати карантинні норми,
а не окремо кімнати, як це робив раніше.
Якщо уряд і це заборонить, шукатиме нові варіанти,
як одночасно працювати і не порушувати карантин.
Буду робити договір оренди житла - як варіант, як вихід.
У мене не номери, а будинок. Напишу короткостроковий договір оренди.
Це як один з виходів, коли буде локдаун.
Або ще щось. А по прокату спорядження будемо склитися,
черга, буде дистанція.
Ми готові до будь-якої ситуації
і будемо старатися виконувати всі норми.
Утім, схоже, ні Михайлові, ні іншим підприємцям курортного регіону
експериментувати з карантином не доведеться.
Депутати Поляницької ОТГ, до якої входить і село Яблуниця, і курорт "Буковель",
не планують підтримувати урядові рекомендації
щодо запровадження жорсткого карантину з 8 до 24 січня.
Проти карантину - і влада сусідньої Яремчанської ОТГ.
Карантину, наскільки я спілкувався з депутатами,
ніякого запроваджувати не будемо...
Ми дали команду Яремчанській міській лікарні,
щоб вона готувалася і була готова до якихось моментів непередбачуваних.
На питання, чи не бояться тут санкцій з Києва, коротко відповів:
Всі можуть злитися. Але головне - щоб громада себе добре почувала.
Так як я міський голова, то маю бути за громаду.
Попри те, що Івано-Франківська область стало входить
в топ-п’ятірку областей з найбільшим спалахом "ковіду",
туристів від поїздки в Карпати ніщо не спиняє.
Я вже перехворів і не хвилююся. Сподіваюсь, що в мене є імунітет.
Всі бояться, але всі катаються. Закалятися треба.
Ми цю хворобу на собі відчули. Певний ризик, звісно, був.
Ми це розуміли. Але жага адреналіну перевищує всі страхи.
Ми катаємося притримуємось заходів безпеки.
Підприємцю Івану Яцику було б значно спокійніше працювати,
якби влада розробила рекомендації для роботи витягів.
На самодисципліну туристів він не покладається,
тому продумує варіанти, як контролювати порядок на підйомниках.
На січень планую запросити до охорони правопорядку Нацгвардію,
бо якщо людей буде багато, а люди не хочуть слухати,
, кажуть, що вони безсмертні, бо не вірять, що таки є "ковід".
Я не сумнівався ніколи, і коли перехворів,
то зрозумів, шо ні ті шмотки, ні ті хати
ні бізнес не мають значення, коли людина не здорова.